peu
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous et à toutes et gérard
bonsoir bonsoir vanille et bonsoir nous
a mis devant de nouveaux trucs puisque
la semaine dernière où hier je crois à
nos deux tours ont été trouvés très très
très vite alors de nouveaux trucs le
bouchon s'évade appartenant à monsieur
théo de grenoble il vaut 300 francs et
le sucre désintégrer qui lui aussi vaut
300 francs mais ne sont pas d intégrer
nos six nouveaux candidats que je vous
présente immédiatement candidat numéro à
votre nom monsieur phal et de
marsannay-la-côte et ses housses à
marsannay-la-côte et dijon bien vous
venez de loi j'éspère que vous gagnerez
candidat numéro deux jean jacques au
jour le 17 à lever l'accent du midi
faisait beau dans les 12h candidate
numéro 3 madame dubois geneviève de
vierzon candidate numéro 4 madame wimmer
de courbevoie
c'est le même temps qu'à paris je suis
bien candidement candidat numéro 5
jacques de 20 de ce quoi et ce poids 6
ou 7 à côté de mon corps j'ai très bien
et candidats et merci les études paris 2
paris
ensemble nous regardons les deux
nouveaux trucs le premier le bouchon
s'évada partenaires monsieur théo de
grenoble il vous je vous rappelle 300
francs vidéo et comptable à grenoble
elle nous présente un truc il vous faut
une carafe contenant de l'eau un
flotteur et une aiguille fixé sur le
bouchon à l'intérieur de la carafe le
bouchon va se trouver prisonniers sur
les huits nous plaçons le tout dans la
carafe et nous voyons que le bouchon est
prisonnier sur l'aiguillé il faut
maintenant libéré le bouchon s'en
retirer la tige bien entendu ni
retourner le bouquin comment faire il y
a un truc à vous de le trouver
candidat numéro à monsieur fallen
questions à poser à gérard oui est-ce
que l'on peut pencher la carafe
ah non monsieur il dit bien sont
retournés serait peut être une partie
seulement
non on n'a pas le droit de penser la
carafe candidat numéro de monsieur
kuyole kusion cojaal pardon c'est pas
grave est ce que le fait de donner au
mouvement circulaire à loana pas quand
sur les parois tu peux avoir une
quelconque incidence sur la masse l'usmh
s'est pas trop même
essayez janvry mais vous asseoir alors
ce n était pas une carafe d'ailleurs
instinct flagrante au calme et penser
que peut-être en essayant de faire ceci
alors il est presque sorti des presses
va essayer plus fin ensuite si ça a
peut-être ben qu'oui alors non un truc
non il est toujours là ben moi je crois
que vous avez la solution mais il
faudrait aller beaucoup plus fort oh là
là attention
alors voulez-vous faire mouvement plus
circulaire monsieur un peu voilà à lier
les parties et les parties non non il
est revenue allez hop
dites donc ne jamais été préparateur en
pharmacie et regarder les sorties
n'arriverait il est sorti à temps
pour confirmation vous allez voir
monsieur guy théo de grenoble qui vous
donne sa solution vous allez voir c'est
identique
regardez bien dans sa tribulation c'est
la solution est très simple il suffit de
prendre la caroff et de lui donner un
large mouvement circulaire et ainsi vous
voyez le bouchon libéré de l'accord de
la tige et voilà vous avez gagné les
bien truquée vonnie va vous et vous
gagnez bien sûr 300 francs merci
monsieur d'être venus de 71 nous
regardons tout de suite notre deuxième
truc qui lui vaut 300 francs le sucre
désintégrer un truc avec 3 sucre c3
sucre sont placés dans la main gauche et
maintenant je requiers l'un d'eux que je
pose sur la table il reste dessus
un simple mouvement comme cela sur les
doigts l'un des sucres a disparu et n'en
reste plus qu'un quel est le truc qui
permet cette désintégration candidate
numéro trois maladies du bois
est-ce que vous avez une façon non pas
le mais le sucre ont mal à ma tension
répéter votre question il me semble
qu'il ya un terme technique
est-ce que vous avez une façon de
nombreux disques vous aviez des lampes
allumées l'an palmer en parle mais
madame
peu de gens savent ce que c'est c'est
une expression de prestidigitation vous
connaissez la prestidigitation oui un
petit peu pour employer cette expression
ça veut dire tenir secrètement un
morceau de sucre
je ne pas vous montrer le détail mais ça
permet de montrer voyez un sucre dans la
main de faire semblant de le mettre là
c'est addictif voir le père et à
paraître dans l'autre main madame c'est
de la manipulation et je n'emploie
jamais de manipulation pour nos trucs
simples il ne s'agit pas de vous
expliquer les trucs des
prestidigitateurs ce n'est pas notre
propos est de s'amuser des trucs simples
et là il n'y a pas du tout dans palmage
numéro 4 est ce qu'on manipulant les
sucres et s'il n'y a pas su qu'il
resterait à l'envers bien sûr coincé
quand vous avez votre main comme ça
voyez derrière mais on nie en lisant un
ânon là je serai aussi de la
manipulation je vous le répète encore il
n'y a pas de manipulation ce sont des
trucs très simple qu'en dit la numéro 5
monsieur le vin est ce qu'en réalité il
n'y aurait pas que de sucre c'est à dire
qu'elles n'ont rien qui serait coupé par
le milieu j'en voulais présenter on a
l'impression qu'il y en a 3 commence at
il coupé bien aimée avec moi monsieur
parce que là vous vous exprimer
théoriquement mais je vais voir en
pratique ce que voulait dire voilà avec
deux sucres seulement alors comment
pourrait-on voir ça un coupé chez pas
dans quel sens pour des antilles
attendre à une trop tard
il est présenté comme si la wii bon
alors montré bien monsieur là on montre
elle est reçue oui et maintenant
manipulateur vous les mettez en a même
oui alors il celui qui a tant besoin v
celui qui est entier et il vous reste
deux moitiés de surprises en utilisant
un non on ne pourriez pas le poser des
convaincre il y aurait deux moitiés
monsieur vous êtes proche d'un solution
mais ce n'est pas cela merci monsieur
vous regagnez votre place et nous
passons notre candidat numéro si ce
monsieur si poletti une question à poser
à gérard majax moi je pensais que les
deux morceaux de sucre extrait dans la
main nous te retirer le premier morceau
et les deux autres morceaux
aïe aïe il ya trois morceaux et les deux
restent dans la main et on me voit plus
qu'un nom on présenterait les morceaux
sont coupées la wii a nommé on n'a pas
dit c'est pas vrai mais je sais pas la
solution les trois éléments sont coupées
c'était pas une bonne solution mais ce
nom les morceaux ne sont pas coupés en
vérité aux biens ces deux petits
morceaux dessus qui sont pas de la même
grandeur que les autres ah non non non
mais je ne m'en lasse et fo ces forêts
gérées par des parts dans cette voie ce
n'est pas du tout cela et c'est à notre
candidat numéro un à poser une question
gérard est ce que les morceaux que vous
présentez est ce que le ne serait pas
coller avec l'autre collet oui c'est à
dire vous en lv1 et vous présenter le
morceau mais comprend effectivement
gagné 2 qui resterait l'un venait
montrer monsieur montrer parce que je
veux voir s'ils veulent principe calhoun
on a la solution
voilà les trois l'art par exemple mais
donc ce soit collée monsieur oui sa main
pendant deux ans et l'autre serait
derrière cacher non monsieur on
risquerait de le voir on voit nettement
vous verrez dans le film ce n'est pas
cela une personne était proche de la
solution et en cassant du sucre à elle
et elle a dérivé est venu vers une
solution qui étaient fausses mais on va
trouver ça n'est pas cela
et pour une prochaine émission via le
sucre désintégrer vaudra 600 francs et
un tout nouveau truc appartenant à
monsieur qu'union de paris la boîte
ensorcelé on les regarde ensemble si
vous voulez bien au revoir à bientôt un
truc avec 3 sucre c3 sucre sont placés
dans la main gauche et maintenant je
retire l'un d'eux que je pose sur la
table il reste dessus
un simple mouvement comme cela sur les
doigts lundi sucre a disparu et n'en
reste plus qu'un quel est le truc qui
permet cette désintégration gérard
clients et éducateurs et fait souvent
des tours aux enfants aujourd'hui nous
en montre à cette boîte d'allumettes
obéi aux ordres de même je vais leur
classe et sur ce gobelet renversé
voilà elle est en équilibre elle est en
équilibre
regardez bien même ces mouvements de
doigts sont spéciaux à la la boîte les
comprend elle ne peut résister à leurs
impulsions vous arrivez à attirer la
boîte
absolument
et la boîte tombe pas dans la personne
non mais écoutez vous ferez croire cela
à qui vous voulez moi je sais que vous
avez un truc et il s'agit de le trouver
[Musique]